a small place uh kind of off the beaten
track um it's not what we would have
expected for such a great champion for
such a famous person simply so
um yeah it made me a bit emotional i
must say i can imagine well uh
everything's happening today we are
jumping straight into this game richard
report is taking on
lavon aronian now playing for the us and
uh they have both been struggling a
little bit so far in the tournament um
and richard with the white pieces in
this game so what kind of opening are we
looking at um it's the sicilian defense
but i think i want to pass this one on
to simon um it's not the most usual
sicilian right no i mean i've seen
richard do the stuff before
and this is why so many people love
richard as a player
because he's bonkers basically
and we're we were talking about
personality reflecting in their in their
chess play
and i don't know what richard is you
know i don't know him so well but the
the strange move dave this is g4 right
and and this is a way to try and gain
space on the king side it actually makes
some sense but it is
a very committal move pawns can't go
backwards as we've seen um so it's a
yeah it's a unique position maybe
already right possibly
at least i mean
now we're in new territory before that
only one game had ever been played like
this um it seemed to be a trendy idea
actually you know i see i saw a few
grandmasters try it out in 2021 2020
something i've never actually seen
before
but uh okay i'm uh
all eyes i want to know what this idea
is and the funny thing is uh this
variation so white started okay
obviously it's richard report he's gonna
put a knight on the edge of the board at
some point unexpectedly he's just done
that now but uh this variation with uh
g4 on move three i actually recommended
this to a student of mine uh i think it
was a couple of years ago and they were
like no no no it's too ugly it's
do you know anything about chess and i
was like wait who's the teacher here
who's the student
um so yeah i mean it has a lot of point
what white is doing what is gaining all
the space on the king side because
that's likely where black's king would
love to castle
um i'm not sure that's going to happen
any time soon aronian look at his pieces
they're just not out and
meanwhile rapport grabbing all the space
yes irony has grabbed space on the queen
side but that's less relevant right now
and
i think the space grab that ironian's
made it only makes it less likely that
aronian's king is going um towards that
side of the board so
yeah it's uh it's such a weird wacky
position that it's hard to draw kind of
specific conclusions about it because we
will see more surprises over the next
few moves but either way white's set up
does have some logic and at least he's
better developed than black right now
well this is the first game today for
levon aronian actually because uh he was
supposed to meet team rajabov in the
first game today but rajabov is out he
pulled out because he is sick so that
was a walk over when for levon and let's
take a look at the results from the
previous round we did have uh quite a
few draws in that one but levon aronian
he did get three points against the team
rajab of duda in a dramatic game against
arjun neriga you see three points for
duda
a win for him against vojtacek and
lenia dominguez we did see him win his
game against jew engine so the standings
and please interrupt me if something
dramatic happens on the board but
standings right now we still have sam
sevilla on top of the table 21 points
two points ahead of the young christophe
duda it's all about the youngsters look
at that jeffrey shong uh in third place
with arjun nergaiti on the same score
mamadiar of the uh oldest player right
now towards the top of the table anish
gary is inside top eight and so is levon
aronian and so is richard report right
now but i did see our stats genius tai
uh update that uh currently only 52
chance to qualify so we need still
points to secure a spot in the knockouts
and we do have fuels we do have a few
moves and it's really heating up
it's only move 11 but white is burning a
lot of bridges in order to launch an
attack against the black king and
black's king did indeed commit uh to
this side of the board so richard's
saying okay i'm going to go straight for
you and simon this really reminds me of
a dutch defense just with colours
reversed and it's like a super powered
version for white it does yeah i mean
it's a nice little pyramid he's created
as well i kind of like these patterns
you know that pawn chain four pawns in a
row uh supported but this is this is
exactly what you're saying earlier david
i mean you know forget about what the
computer says uh chess is often about
king safety
and it's also about getting the type of
position you enjoy playing and uh i
think nearly everyone prefers attacking
rather than defending it's much more fun
in general that's not everyone but
nearly everyone and uh richard is
certainly one of those players so he's
picked an opening that gets him into a
position where he can attack where he
gets out of theory he he's not really a
theory man and he can have some fun and
um
that that f pawn which you get in the
dutch is going straight up the board
towards black's king and i would be
feeling actually very uncomfortable if i
was black here just because i can see a
lot of a lot of things happening uh in
this position so um yeah i mean it's
it's looking like what richard wants
anyway this this position yeah yeah it
looks good doesn't it it does yeah i
mean to me i mean it looks very scary i
mean the the white knight on the rim has
some lovely ways into the position um as
well and uh you know there's a it's just
the black king is is a target oh look at
it
he literally doesn't care does he he's
just going straight in you know i love
this move for two reasons firstly it
looks like a pawn storm but he's also
opened up a path for her majesty the
queen to enter the attack
this looks super scary as yeah it's
definitely breaking a lot of rules it's
very committal but if it works if he
wins this game quickly
so for example you know just to
elaborate on your queen move you know
that would be very to say black makes
some non moves and then we could see a
nice mating attack that went uh
um
yeah queen and then suddenly the pawn f
pawn comes and uh
once that pawn steps forward
or this pawn steps forward okay yeah
yeah then you can come in i mean
it's like forget what the computer is
saying oh black's a little bit better
this is where you've got to turn off the
computer because just facing this it's
like literally you're stuck in the
middle of a road and a bulldozer is just
coming towards you and you freeze and
it's like oh my words if you get out the
way you'll be okay but you've got to get
out of the way and
actually it's now shot up the computer
in in richard's favor and i would not be
surprised if there's some big move here
maybe f6 or something david yeah so if
we backtrack just in this position black
decided to get rid of one of the white
knights makes sense but he's lost the
bishop and
simon you mentioned f6 why not f for
forward and uh f for forward means
throwing the f pawn forward and
yeah it could be fatal
i i mean i love it when richard plays
like this he's a joy to watch because
there's not many top players you can
play you know get out of theory or move
four or five and and then destroy
someone as strong as irony and i don't
know if that's going to happen but um
he's just he's just going straight for
it i mean you mentioned caveman this is
caveman chess at its best uh you know
he's attacking a knight he's trying to
rip uh the shelter around black's king
open one thing black should never get
tempted to do is play pawn takes pawn
right now because suddenly the black
king is just
doomed uh it's just on an open line
there are squares around to check mate
it
the white queen is going to come in the
white bishop's going to come in
everything is pouring forward so black
cannot touch the spawn he needs to maybe
move his knight out the way but where uh
that is the big question maybe i was
about to say maybe this square just to
blockade white's pawn here so for
example pawn takes pawn now would likely
be met by just a rug move and
black now would use the white pawn as
shelter it's a bit of a weird pawn
structure actually the uh the irish
pawns yeah
this is uh triple pawns yeah it's not
ideal long term for white of course but
uh short term you have
kind of conquered the dark squares here
so uh what is the follow up that's the
question here do you capture this pawn
do you leave the tension you just take a
timeout to maybe capture this pawn in
the center instead
he's taking the pawn and oh okay he does
he does capture the key
but uh okay
but now the queen can come in and
it's super tempting for the queen to
come in maybe for the night to start
doing a dance towards the black king
lots of options for white i love this
idea of the night moving in david i mean
i i i guess black can at least exchange
it off yeah i mean that knight coming in
that route you mentioned is is a really
scary idea
uh and you can also see um the dark
square bishop uh if you know you've got
to look at all your pieces when you're
attacking you should look at your pieces
near your opponent's king can they do
anything david pointed out that knight
jumping in
but then you've got to try to involve
all your army it is your army and again
david highlighting a piece there which
looks looks like you know the dark
squares let's get it on lined up against
the king and there's some obvious ways
you can do that by for example david
pointing out here putting it on that
diagonal so there's a lot of lot of
tempting options here maybe maybe that's
the only problem that richard has a bit
too many tempting options in some way
yeah he's barely paused for thought
until this move richard this is the
first time he spent more than one minute
for a move and it's because he realizes
his position is so promising for white
this bishop if it enters the action it's
unchallenged on the dark squares it will
conquer the dark squares and simply win
the game so if he can get this piece
into the play
it's not clear how this move that i
mentioned getting onto the diagonal
looks nice and uh pretty but at some
point at least uh i'm not sure what
black plays but at least you can block
it out with this pawn for now so this
diagonal you can't quite conquer it yet
um just too many tempting options i'd be
still so tempted to move the night
around this way maybe to even retreat oh
yeah
this is very clever because he's
avoiding that night exchange but going
for your same plan well it looks clever
i don't know if it is but it it makes
sense as well even if the computer hates
it
people will hate any human move yeah but
yeah you want to recapture this pawn
this pawn for black is stuck right now
due to a pin along this diagonal so
black central pawn is going to drop and
then the material will be balanced but
also the white knight might want to
sneak around this way
uh first ironian attacks this
foot soldier this guy okay that's clever
uh it's attacking this pawn but also
defending the bishop so that the pin is
broken along the uh long light square
diagonal yeah maybe this is uh something
that richard
might have underestimated is this a real
threat to take this pawn for the black
queen
i think it is actually i mean i think
the queen is within touching distance of
her king because the natural move that i
was thinking about is just ignore the
pawn introduce the queen into the game
but
then again black's queen is very active
and suddenly you can start thinking
about some counter-attacking
possibilities as well this is very sharp
isn't it totally sharp is wild it's what
we love about chess
we don't quite know what's happening and
that deep dark forest of uh
complications
yeah so it's really sharp let's see what
the players come up with and
i'm really excited about what's coming
because i have a feeling this game is
going to end in some checkmating attack
i'm just not sure who's going to be
checkmating who uh at the moment it
looks like white's been doing all the
running but richard still needs that uh
momentum that creativity to continue
yeah
and uh obviously okay he's going for a
more sensible approach here okay um
and i suppose the point is the black
knight is going to be
attacked
in some variation so so if this knight i
mean white's knight is so strong maybe
he has to remove it
what's his plan if it gets removed you
know it's going to be
i guess he wanted to take wants to take
with the pawn to stop black going queen
takes pawn but you don't really want to
take the pawn in general do you i mean
it's a
i think erroneous chances have improved
by this
yeah maybe we can just show this because
it's a really critical moment and
uh yeah taking with the night is strange
to me especially the fact that he only
spent a minute or two on this move
because it is such a crazy position um
both players really
trusting their instincts in this game so
far but this knight is too strong for
white in the center so black should
remove it he has just done so and as
simon mentioned the whole idea must be
to take with the pawn because if you
take the bishop now then this queen can
swoop in with a check and this is really
really frustrating because the king
would love to hide in the corner it just
gets checked again at the very minimum
and at the very minimum black force a
draw if you drop back with a bishop to
block now suddenly black is the one
attacking you
the queen bishop uh the queen sorry and
the knight attacking the bishop
this doesn't look ideal black's also a
pawn up so it's the idea to just
recapture all the pawn but then
suddenly you've blocked your own bishop
in and these guys are all isolated
black's got lovely outposts in front of
that pawn as well i mean uh you can kick
these knights away now yeah so this is
uh this is looking better for aronia
than it was i think oh hang on a second
okay typically typical
he doesn't care take a pawn with check
oh but will we see a draw will we see
aronian just try to give checks with the
queen try to repeat the position
i don't know here i think richard knew
that he'd blown it slightly and uh yes
he's attacking the black rook but
if the black rook moves maybe he has
time to start coordinating his pieces
bringing the white queen out for example
but the question is if black wants a
draw
does aronia want to draw is richard
gambling on the fact that avronian will
go for the win allowing him to play for
the win as well
difficult moment
and uh yeah you called it that rapport
is just happy with the draw he's just
taken a lean back on his chair meanwhile
aronian there and his basketball shirts
he is considering but we've actually
seen aronian refuse draws you know he's
actually consistently played for the win
and now as we're closing in on the last
day of the preliminaries he has to go
for something
it's his moment right
oh
such a tense moment it does come with
risk if you play for the win it could
rebound that's happened several times on
aronian will he be scarred by those
memories playing for a win against eric
gaici
losing that game
we got to take a bet right what do you
think do you think he's going to be
happy with the draw
i think he'll play for a win um
i
i'll start it off i don't know why i
think he will
so there you go how about you ivanka
i think he will play for the win as well
i think he'll take the draw okay
all bets are on uh what do you guys at
home also think is going to happen will
erroneous risk it or we'll be satisfied
with the draw tweet us using the hashtag
chestcharms and okay oh it looks like
david is going to
maybe edge our bets
but uh this is very professional
just repeat the position there we go you
guys were right here we go
no draw no repetition no draw yeah i
think
that's because i think the queen check's
quite clear because it stops white's
queen going to that square um and
i mean ronian is a real fighter if
there's any way he can play on then then
he will um so that's what he's done yeah
and uh the two knights are not
necessarily worse than
the two bishops right now black also has
an extra pawn which does
kind of help a decision to take a risk
and play on uh to avoid a draw
so it's all up to rapport now how can
those kind of lazy queen side pieces the
white queen the white bishop and the
white rook in the corner how did they
join the action
if you're pawn down you need them to
start uh playing as a team those white
pieces
i'm expecting the white queen to develop
i'm not sure exactly where
and uh yeah it's really complex still
the evaluation bar might have finally
settled down towards the center but
that's not to say the position is calm
it's still a weird wild position
and okay attacking the black queen this
bishop drops back
this makes some sense i guess just
forcing the black queen to make a
decision she might get kicked around a
few times on her way out of white's
white's camp there
i i'm still slightly surprised he played
for the winner onion i'm a bit gutted i
lost that bet
did we have anything on the bet because
we used to we used to have it we didn't
bet anything i think you're in the world
championship so you actually you owe me
quite a bit yeah
the old beer or should we say like four
or five yeah so i think we need to
introduce this again
yeah the white rook lifting
you love these kind of rook swing ideas
simon i do yeah i i love the rook
swinging over i mean we talked about the
swinger uh plenty of times in the past
and uh it's it's covering a lot of
squares here
but i'm just trying to work out whose
king is weaker here and i'm i'm actually
thinking maybe richard's king is
actually the one which could be in a
little bit more danger
in some variations i mean the black
knights can jump forwards i don't know
if you want to do that straight away the
black rook
um has potential um which is at the
moment stuck behind the black knight but
there's quite a lot of ideas here david
i guess that black has maybe black's got
more ideas than white easier to play as
you mentioned the knight could jump
forward and then the black rook could
start swinging down into white's camp
but
iranian i mean these two players love to
surprise us right and uh
in this position what a move
not sure this would even cross my radar
to be honest
it's so counter-intuitive always to
allow on passant to capture
like this and
is this tempting right now should white
capture this pawn as if it just moved to
one square or should white leave it and
just
maybe get on with swinging his rook
across hoping that
for example if the queen comes he can
block and then at some point the white
queen can come into the attack
it looks really complicated maybe
erroneous idea is to offer a queen trade
here
to stop the white queen from entering uh
the black half
black is still this one pawn up and
eddie queen at any queen exchange might
well favor him suddenly as you mentioned
the black knights are coming black
knight could dance into this square
still unclear to be honest who's better
in the same game
it's such a weird position totally weird
uh i
somehow my vibe is saying to me that
white perhaps shouldn't capture the pawn
should instead leave it on the board i
agree with you perhaps the end game is
the best chance you know like what does
have the bishop pair
you know they're very it's a very
powerful weapon they can create a lot of
damage so i'm predicting that the rook
will attack the queen yeah the problem
with capturing on pass on here is that
the black pieces will come into the
action maybe the night maybe the rook
and uh
actually maybe with a rook just so that
you can meet this one with a check
still mighty complicated though
yeah i mean i think i think ironian's
last move you said that maybe
you wouldn't think about the smooth day
but it's a class move isn't it f5 is
really a clever move because also by
using that pawn you're grabbing some
more squares for black you know that
that pawn is controlling more squares
and your opponent's half and uh yeah it
just looks like a good move and i i it
kind of feels like richard's position is
it's kind of like getting worse worse
here worse and worse move by move
the bishops not really doing anything
the black knights look more scary and
black's pawn up as well so
uh good good decision by uh erodian to
turn down the draw in the end yeah at
least in practical terms it feels like
he's still got some control yeah quite a
lot of control so yeah let's see how the
players react they have slowed down i
thought this game would be
a bit like some of erroneous games
yesterday where um i don't know if
you're watching simon but when he played
hans nieman for example
i mean i think they were removed 35 and
aronian still had more time than he
started with
but uh okay we did see on-pass on a porn
exchange there and this variation we
showed black giving a check
it looks so dangerous of white this
position and for black but really
just dangerous doesn't it
danger danger
well i guess he has to get rid of that
night now doesn't he
too good yeah yeah yeah there are some
traps here for example if you bring the
white queen forward and give a check i
think that would actually backfire um
maybe we can show this because uh yeah
of a very very sneaky move here aronian
is threatening checkmate in one move
he's threatening to take this bishop
with his queen
trapping the white king and uh if white
does give a check it looks like you're
counter attacking here against the black
king but suddenly the black rook will
just sidestep blocking a white queen if
it moves if it captures the knight for
example still this is checkmate because
the black queen now is protected by its
rook
uh so that would be a huge blunder as
simon mentions
i mean
if it were a blitz game at least i
wouldn't even calculate just remove that
knight and richard does that
the queen steps back to capture whose
king is safer that's still the key
question right that is suddenly white is
threatening some checkmating ideas
taking this pawn hitting the black king
what normally happens in these crazy
games everything gets swapped off you
get to a very boring ending and it's a
draw
it's always the way i don't know why
that is you get the most you know
stupidly crazy positions and just
everything like calms down but we could
even see that now can we i mean like
white has a very strong threat you know
this is double power the queen and the
rook and black can maybe move the rook
to for some exchanges if he wishes he's
a porn up you can certainly think about
going into an ending and then everything
yeah everything you can get hoovered off
what do you think about descending as
you mentioned porn up but winning
chances well i mean i think
you know white's doing okay here with
that move you're pointing out and
black's pawns are very weak
in this position so i wouldn't afford
i wouldn't thought white's in too much
danger in this ending black could be in
danger in some positions even i don't
know what do you think rook and bishop
tend to work a bit better than rook and
knight in general and yeah you're right
lots of weaknesses to deal with
for example if the knight drops back you
can start going after these pawns as
well
i think uh this this is not what aronian
wanted when he turned down that
opportunity to draw earlier so
he'll be looking at something else in
the current position but what else do
you drop back with the knight to defend
this pawn knight on f8 there is no mate
but uh you do lose this one
suddenly i'm liking white's chances yes
i'm so
it's keeping us all in suspense as well
that's what we like about chess you know
anything happen all three results are
possible
and uh
you know
there's no such thing as an easy game
actually you know you still have to find
the moves and uh it looks like we might
be headed into the territory of the uh
the end game that david earlier showed
us that we're black is to pawn up but
still not out of danger still a lot of
excitement to be had and uh you know the
kid players are keeping us entertained
with their spectacular chess and of
course we love to see when you guys get
involved in the action so please share
with us how you're watching the tour
from you know show us where where in the
world you're watching us who you're
watching with maybe some animals we do
like our pets and you can do that by
tweeting us using the hashtag
chesschamps and we will feature them on
the show
yeah uh we haven't seen a really uh
little dog for a while have we no
projects probably in the u.s right i
think they brought panchok to the us
when they moved
he couldn't have left it in armenia
he can't leave this dog in armenia he
can't do that [ __ ] mascot no
he's got to take it to america yeah it's
actually quite complicated right
yeah especially america he probably
needs a passport he needs to be id'd
make sure he's not in a threat to the
national security um medical check
yeah medical check yeah probably a long
process so
i hope he's got his dog
i think he does i think it's uh in the
u.s where he lives in st louis but right
now levon is playing from armenia his uh
birth country
and he revealed to us a few days ago
that it is because he is
sort of
transferring over to um india where the
olympiad will be played in a few weeks
he is uh going to be on the american
team
and uh
armenia is closer to india than the us
yeah i think unfortunately we won't see
rapport
at the olympiad oh uh he hasn't yet
transferred over to romania and i guess
he won't be playing for hungary
so that'll be a big one
david would you ever obviously you live
in norway now you're an englishman
um really but would you ever consider
your good friends of magnus you know if
magnus sort of said david i need you i
need you to become norwegian you know um
here's a million i am
that's how high the braves if it's a
millionaire maybe i think that would
attempt anything it's a million euros
i think england need me more than norway
though definitely we need you in england
david we need you
nowhere fourth seeds at the olympiad
it's incredible it's amazing yeah i mean
this this event coming up soon is yeah
it's incredible yeah let's hope they do
better than their female football team
shall we yes
meanwhile some exchanges have happened
on the board we mentioned the queen's
rooks disappearing this end game white
was upon down white has regained the
pawn and the cost of trading off the
bishop for night and now it's a pure
rook end game and uh
i think unfortunately for
rapport and iranian fans this one is
fizzling out towards a draw
that doesn't really suit either player
in the tournament standings both really
wanted to win now after another pawn
capture temporarily white to pawn up but
this check
is ironian's plan and look at this the
black rook is getting greedy it's going
to grab a pawn on the next move as well
and
yeah everything's disappeared exactly
what we said exactly you called it just
the most interesting game pieces
everywhere we don't know what's going on
rook ending draw you know it's just the
way karma you did say yeah 15 moves ago
you said yes that's just how it just
works right yeah it just happens that
way doesn't it sometimes it's strange
yeah especially when both players are
equally talented both players are
equally kind of sharp and seeing
everything and it's actually been quite
a high quality game i think yeah
totally despite the weird quirky start
yeah i mean it happens
fizzles out
to a draw draw is the perfect result
for chess i mean i think i saw an
interview i think it was actually with
napomyashi where he said that uh
draw is the perfect psychological result
of a game you don't feel
high you don't feel any lows when you
win you kind of have some adrenaline
rushes and uh when you lose you also
feel some dejection so
it's you get a neutral state from a game
like this
and this is good for the brain
apparently and the mindset there are
different types of drawers sometimes
you're completely winning you mess it up
and it's a draw you're depressed if
you're completely losing you save it
draw you're on top of the world so i
mean i feel that's a lot of rubbish i
prefer winning so
exactly you know winning's much better
surely yeah much better feeling yeah but
don't you find that sometimes when
you're winning you start thinking about
the future and you can't necessarily go
to sleep that easily yeah but it's an
exciting feeling you know i don't mind
that feeling well okay i mean it's nice
to be excited because you've got chance
in the tournament next game's coming up
and uh it's a really good feeling i
think that's why you know why we play
chess a lot of winning you know it's not
the taking part it's the winning
why i got into the game when i was
little because i just couldn't help
myself i love the winning i think when
people say oh you know you know it's the
taking part that counts rubbish
i don't think it is maybe a little bit
but it's you know you want to win don't
you i mean if you lost every game you
played you wouldn't really be enjoying
yourself would you i think that's how
people truly fall in love with chess in
the first place is the winning and then
they appreciate the beauty later
at least that's uh how most people i've
spoken to yeah experience it and
meanwhile neither side will be winning
this game it's just one pawn against one
porn and
easy draw the white king is just going
to sit and wait the white rook will wait
there's no way to actually attack this
last remaining
white pawn if anyone's on the better
side of a draw it's black right now
but uh just because black's king and
rook are more active it's not enough
not much has to be said i think ironian
might try one or two little tricks but
rapport has seven and a half minutes
he's not gonna blunder this one away
well um easy start to the day then for
lavon orronian this is the first game he
plays today because uh the first one was
a
walkover win against rajapov who pulled
out of the tournament
and this one should also be
a quite quick one for the armenian and
uh when the fin game finishes we'll jump
into
the game between wei yi and jeffrey jong
jeffrey he had a fantastic start to the
tournament winning three games in a row
and he is currently in third place doing
very well the young american
and i guess we're getting close to
that draw
yep
simply no way to win white's remaining
porn if black somehow manages to attack
it white will counter-attack by going
for the black pawn and
unfortunately you can't achieve both of
those things at the same time you can't
attack white's porn while keeping your
own pawns safe
for aeronian here so
yeah not much to play for
unfortunately it looks like just a draw
doesn't it i mean
yes if the pawns disappear rook versus
rook easy draw yeah
although i might be tempted to play that
one up till
grind like a grand master
if they trade pawns in four moves and
then they can play 50 moves uh 50 move
rule with just the rooks you get to move
100. what i'm looking forward to most
about your course david a lot of the
chess ball courses are becoming books
yeah and i want to see what the front
cover of that book will be you know
that's what yeah i just want to see
i just want to see i've got some images
in mind um you know
david yeah i'll think of something
especially
yeah
so yeah it might be a diagram of that
beautiful game six from the 2021 world
championship match but okay here we go
this is exactly what we were discussing
as soon as black goes for the white's
pawn the black pawn will be attacked
yeah and
you have to be slightly careful here
yeah but the white king
is in snapping distance it just has to
move itself off the fourth row so there
is no discovered checks
yeah black's big big threat here other
than king takes pawn is to push the
blackball down one square and that is a
check the black rook will hit the white
king
so white's king needs to
quickly move
you can actually retreat it i was about
to say
and uh as soon as black's king goes to
take your pawn the white king can
retreat and kind of cut off
uh we'll see this i think uh happen in a
moment
oh we call shouldering why does the bar
jump up here it's gone a little bit
funny i have to say i mean i i it
doesn't look as simple does it or i
think it's still a draw right
now we'll retreat
take a step opposite yeah so this is the
opposition
i mean you're a pawn now yeah i know
it's a draw the problem is white's rook
will just wait and i don't think black
has a uh okay it's a winning plan also
you can step in front of this pawn this
is the key in in rook and pawn endings
uh there's only one pawn left if you put
your king in front of that pawn
generally it's always a draw right so
this is the ideal thing just get your
king in front of the pawn and use your
rook in the right way and we're going to
probably see that third ranked defense
at some point yeah um actually against
the b and g pawns against knight's pawns
as we call it you can even go really
passive you can just put your rook on
the first rank and just sit there's no
way
uh to win so knight's pawns the b and g
pawns are the worst pawns to have extra
right in these freaking games as simon
mentioned there are other defenses
the philidor defense uh the second
ranked defense there are others uh
against other pawns but
yeah yeah this one you can do anything
yeah we'll see the position repeat
itself
most likely
hey
they're still teasing us yeah he's
still a pawn up
he's hoping here that the rook is
captured
uh is that a draw anyway
no it's not a draw if you capture the
rook so
you've got to be slightly careful but
you can just move your king forward and
a rook and game will lead to this
rook exchange will lead to this dead
drawn king a pawn end game you have to
be slightly careful where you put the
white king but there we go the game ends
in stalemate it's the draw